we are here with philanthropist
activists oh and lady gaga's mom uh
cynthia germanotta
okay so if you're sitting at a table
with her is there anything that you can
think of that she would say about
how she sort of matriculated that pain
of the bullying and
the way that she felt into channeling it
into something that was more empowering
um
and useful
to her yeah i i think she would say um
we talk a lot at the foundation about
the impact that kindness has on your
mental health not only
kindness to self she talks about
kindness on the inside and kindness on
the outside and you have to be kind
inside to yourself first before you can
help it's hard
it's look away i look away i'm working
on it do you have any advice for me
baby steps
yeah babies love yourself
i'm trying love yourself
look in the mirror
it's okay to look in the mirror and tell
yourself that you love you
fifty percent of mental health issues
develop by the age of 14
and that's about when it started
happening for my daughter
and but it's not uncommon for it to go
undiagnosed for 10 years and
and i missed the warning signs i didn't
know what they were
and you know we talk to our girls and
our children our boys too about the
birds and the bees right we have that
talk
i call we have to add the flowers and
the trees about their mental health and
having that conversation with them in
the same breath
as the birds and the bees and if there
was one thing that i could leave with
you
or anybody is communication
and there's times they don't want it but
communication
to a fault
i would say and it just keeps that
dialogue open
you know one person in your life can
make a difference and if that one i used
to tell my girls i may not like
everything that you tell me but i would
rather know and be able to help you
and so just having that one person in
your life and we found through our work
at the foundation that that's it's
life-changing and it's life-saving in
many instances if you have just one
person that
is there for you i have looked forward
to this conversation with all of my
heart i admire like i said you and your
family i admire what you're putting out
into the world what you're contributing
to the world how you're taking people
and making them feel safe and the born
this way foundation is making a huge
difference
and um
we're all also you know in love with
your daughter and listening to her
she's modeling a lot for us
i know that's a lot of pressure but she
like steps up to that plate so watching
her be who she is is just a complete
inspiration in every sense of the word
and i think there's
such serious credibility to what you and
your daughter are doing so thank you
thank you yeah thank you
go to our website at the
drewberrymartia.com to learn more about
the born this way foundation
[Music]